you know it's funny we talk about these
things as
accidents but obviously so much training
Hard Work Talent
um you know I've been thinking about
your career
um how your mother uh was uh very famous
uh actress activist and you came from a
long line in Spain of actors and some
people say well it's in it's maybe it
sounds like a cliche to say it's in your
blood but it must be in your blood yeah
this this desire to do it and do it
correctly absolutely and you were very
interested in art as a as a child you
were entertaining I mean were you not
educated as to sort of to be an artist
in some way well I I guess I was born
into it and I saw my mom and my uncle
was the director my mom was an actress
my grandparents were actors so everybody
was working in the thing and but I saw
the I saw more the Downs than the UPS
yeah there was a lot of unemployment
there was a lot of struggle in trying to
make some money but I also saw that the
decency the honesty that the job will
bring to them and and what they will
bring to their job and how much
passionate they were about
uh about their craft yeah and and the
respect they have for nearly
the job but also the people that is in
the job and makes the job with them so I
like that very much I felt that was a
nice way to to go and and once I decided
to become an actor I knew that I have to
really be
responsible for the surname but them
that belongs to many generations and
that's why I always try to do my best us
everybody I mean yeah but you know we
live in this uh culture now where people
want to be famous and they were
interested in being famous and over the
years I've had people that are
interested in doing comedy that say you
know I want to do what you're doing I
want to be famous and I think it's not
the reason to do it being famous just
means you take selfies at a restaurant
um there isn't that much
there's not a lot to it it's a it's a
pretty thin soup there's not a lot of
sustenance to it you really have to love
what you're doing and uh I think that's
important for people to know that I mean
you were thinking you never thought to
yourself I'll make movies
internationally or I'll make movies in
the United States you you thought I
might or I've read anyway that you
thought this might be I might just work
in my whole life in Spain absolutely as
an actor and that would be fine I not
only that I I thought I I may be I may
not be able to make a living out of this
but I don't know what to do else I don't
know what else to do I mean I'm not I'm
very clumsy I don't know I don't know
anything you know what many of the
actors I know and actresses are very
like me like they only know how to
perform they don't know how to do
anything else and that's fine if you
know at least to do one thing in your
life and you're lucky enough to make a
living out of that you are blessed and I
guess I bet on that and I bet on that
and I've always seen
my steps like uh as you were saying with
Silva in the sky for like Little Steps
like I never imagined or thought of
myself going to anything big or
achieving this or that it's like what if
I make
this job and I and it's good enough for
them to call me again and thus still
what I think of when I make a movie or
make something is like okay is that
really bad is that bad enough for them
not to call me or or can I keep on going
and and that's something that I guess I
got from my family because everybody was
waiting for the phone to ring and I
guess I have that fear still like it's
not gonna ring anymore but that's fine
because that gives me the drive yeah the
Nerf and the drive yeah did you ever
think to yourself how do I make this
jump or did they come to you were you
recognized and people said okay we have
to get Javier Bardem and that's how it
how it happened
no I I it's funny it's it's it's it's
one accident after the other I mean my
two biggest
movies that really open the market to me
in Spain and out of Spain were
accidental one the one hamon Jamon uh I
was a company my sister to make an
audition
and I watch it in down near near her and
then they asked me do you want to come
in and do an audition as a Nightline I
wonder yeah come in okay and they gave
me the job and and and before night
falls apart your sister won
put on this wig same with the Bond film
another wig yeah exactly your sister was
this close to being silver and then you
had to go to the audition with her
and the other one before they fought
with Julian's novel I met him in a party
in New York and he said you would you
like to make a movie in English and it's
like no I don't want it and speak
English I said well why don't you try
and read this and and I was going to
play this little role and I said okay
I'll try to I'll play that as a as an
experiment but then the person who was
going to play the lead Phillip art from
the priate and he told me will you do it
no I don't I don't want to do it yeah
you are doing it you have a month I said
oh okay I'll try and then I did it
but I know I never expected that anybody
will watch that movie yeah and it
happened that I was nominated for an
Oscar for it which is weird because I
thought nobody's gonna watch it who
cares I'm just gonna see if I can play
in English so
but don't you think other movies that I
thought this is a masterpiece yeah they
were like buried that happens that
happens again and again and again in
this business it's never the thing you
think absolutely you think okay this is
it and it's not and sometimes I I try
and encourage people because there have
been times in my life where the thing
that I thought was going to really make
me early on when I was younger didn't
happen and then I could see later on if
that thing had happened the thing I was
meant to do wouldn't have happened it's
all gets very mystical but I believe in
it I believe there's something to it you
should try podcast
[Laughter]
all right
I just about ran out
um
Eduardo I just have to keep saying
Eduardo to fill it out Eduardo
the word is
let's see